[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débat politique
c'était la seule épreuve encore
maintenus l'oral de français du bac a
finalement était elle aussi annulée
jeudi par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale un bac 2020 noté uniquement
sur contrôle continu seuls les notes
supérieures à 10 sur 20 validé dans
certaines facultés
ce sont les multiples conséquences de la
crise sanitaire les étudiants français
ont-ils des diplômes au rabais
cette année c'est la question du débat
ce soir à nous sommes avec eux à nicolas
bailly ce cofondateur de la république
en marche
bonsoir nicolas vaïsse nous sommes
également avec jean paul huchon
président honoraire du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france bonsoir jean paul huchon
n'est si beaucoup à tous les deux de
débattre ce soir sur rtl françois
écouter d'abord jean michel blanquer
et on en parle après nous entendons donc
l'argument qui considère que
l'évaluation la plus juste des
connaissances des élèves en français et
de prendre en compte les notes des deux
premiers trimestres de l'année et donc
par conséquent l'épreuve orale de
français sera validée par le contrôle
continu
et voilà donc c'était la dernière
nouvelle concernant les examens cette
année jean paul huchon
cet oral de français le ministre de
l'éducation il tenait beaucoup pourtant
est ce que il a dû céder il ya une
concertation évidemment avec les
syndicats comment faut-il le prendre
pas forcément très bien parce que la
valeur du diplôme a été déjà handicapées
par les décisions précédentes mais
apparemment l'organisation d'une épreuve
orale aurait été extrêmement complexe
aurait pu aurait pu gêner les étudiants
seul ali je pense vraiment que cette
année scolaire 2020 est vraiment une
indice colère pas tout à fait perdu mais
assez largement avec beaucoup de retard
à rattraper
vous avez vécu mai 68 jean paul huchon
c'était aussi une année perdue comment
est-ce qu'elle quelle honte et en
quelles ont été les conséquences ou
qu'il avait vécu bon souvenir n'est pas
aussi négatif que ça je pense que à
l'époque les étudiants étaient en
révolte ou les obtenir des modifications
dans leur cycle d'études dans la manière
dont sont organisés les examens etc
et ça n'a pas beaucoup handicapé les
aides pour ma part je je dois dire que
j'ai passé beaucoup des examens en 68
l'aixois n'a pas été catastrophique
donc on est s'était pas tout à fait donc
la même situation nicolas vice votre
votre réaction il n'y aura pas de bac
cette année pour de nombreux lycéens les
lycées professionnels seront
prioritaires pour la reprise des cours
est-ce que vous pensez que la méthode en
tout cas de la reprise de l'école en
général a été la bonne par le
gouvernement alors que l'allemagne a
fait le contraire on valoir
est-ce que c'était la bonne je saurais
vous le dire en tout cas c'était celle
qui s'est imposée à nous de manière
naturelle et sur les conseils du du
comité scientifique qui a conseillé le
président et le gouvernement tout au
long de tout au long de cette épreuve
comme jean paul huchon je regrette cette
décision pour l'épreuve du bac français
par contre j'apporterai un petit bémol
sur la comparaison avec mai 68
pour deux raisons tout d'abord jean paul
huchon l'a rappelé les étudiants qui ont
eu des diplômes en mai 68 n'ont pas été
sanctionnés dans les années qui ont
suivi d'avoir eu un diplôme en 68 plutôt
qu'en 67 ou en 69 et je pense que la
grande majorité des étudiants qui auront
un diplôme en 2020 ne seront pas
sanctionnés de ne pas l'avoir mur de huy
19 ou en 2021
il a une chose aussi qui vous rappeler
par rapport à mai 68 c'est que là les
enseignants ont été exemplaires en 68
c'était une grève générale les lycéens
les étudiants étaient dans la rue leurs
enseignants s'il n'y avait pas de suivi
pédagogique là pendant cette période des
choses se sont mises en place pour que
les et les lycéens et les étudiants
d'université puisse continuer à suivre
leurs cours là on ne parle que des
examens mais en
pas de lacunes ou d'absences
d'enseignement pendant pendant toute
cette période 2-2 contre le mans oui bon
film mais juste avant nicolas bailly
c'est ce que veut le fait que les
étudiants aient suivi les cours ne
justifie pas que ces épreuves soient
maintenus ce spectacle où certaines
petites parties n'ai pas pu les suivre
ses cours il faut sanctionner la
majorité vous savez magali une grande
partie des examens auront lieu quand
même des universités se sont adaptés
sont passés des cuisses est ma distance
font passer des examens à distance
il a aussi énormément d'étudiants dont
le diplôme est sanctionné à quand on
rend en est quand on est dans un masters
par exemple on doit rendre à mémoire ce
mémoire sera rendu sera corrigé donc
être une grande partie des épreuves qui
seront quand même un qui sont quand même
maintenu bien sûr les épreuves
symboliques telles que le l'oral du bac
français où les épreuves du bac
elles n'auront pas lieu et là on n'a
plus affaire à des symboles qu'à une
vraie problématique politique la vraie
problématique pas gagner aujourd'hui et
il faut être honnête avec tous ces
jeunes là c'est de savoir si cette
génération 2020 qui va subir de plein
fouet la crise économique lié aux
coronavirus réussir à son entrée dans le
monde du travail
avant l'arrivée de la génération 2021
année prochaine
oui l'extrême quasi non c'est une très
bonne analyse effectivement jean paul
huchon on a le les préconisations du
groupe de travail de la banque mondiale
qui disait il faut d'abord évidemment
rattraper le temps perdu et aussi
prioriser ceux qui ont des échéances de
deux diplômes à passer priorité
justement à ses élèves
c'est ce qu'a fait l'allemagne et la
france ne l'a pas fait alors comment
analysez vous ces deux ces deux voies
ces deux choix
je pense que les décisions finales ne
sont pas encore prises par le ministre
de l'éducation ni par le gouvernement
mais indiscutablement la solution
allemande est séduisant parce qu'elle
permettrait d'allonger la durée de
l'étude la durée de l'année et sans
doute de rattraper une part du temps
perdu
en gros on considère que ya 40% de temps
c'est beaucoup il faudrait se rapprocher
d'un chiffre plus acceptable alors on va
justement écouté le directeur des lycées
de berlin lui à une solution écoutez le
les élèves vont rater jusqu'à environ
40% du temps scolaire il est important
de rattraper ce temps particulièrement
pour les élèves déjà en difficulté dans
les quartiers difficiles
les calendriers décalé cela existe déjà
donc berlin pourrait décider de décaler
d'un semestre éventuellement plus si la
pandémie se prolonge
nicolas valises décalé le calendrier
c'est à dire vraiment rattraper le temps
perdu est ce que c'est possible en
france
rogner sur les vacances scolaires par
exemple ce serait possible tout est
possible vous savez magali tout est
possible rien n'est pour le moment à
quitter comme l'a rappelé jean paul
huchon
les décrocheurs sont au coeur même de la
politique du gouvernement
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on a voulu
une réouverture partielle des écoles dès
le 11 mai c'est pour ce public très
particulier des décrocheurs aujourd'hui
on ne sait tous tous les ai tous les
élèves tous les étudiants ne sont pas
forcément équipés comme il le faut pour
suivre des cours à distance
tous n'ont malheureusement pas forcément
des parents qui les accompagnent
et il ya des vrais distanciation
sociales qui sont en train de le secret
des vraies fausses et et c'est pour ça
que ces décrocheurs sont au coeur de la
politique du gouvernement
frei on voit justement apparaître à
l'écran les résultats du bac 61,7 % il y
à 50 ans jean paul huchon plus de 20
points de plus
aujourd'hui on parle du bac un bien
évidemment qui n'aura pas lieu cette
année
beaucoup disent finalement le bac n'a
plus la même importance qu'il ya
cinquante ans on le voit bien puisque
finalement ce que disent ses détracteurs
c'est qu'on le donne à tout le monde
si c'est une politique qui a maintenant
de longues années des rays la
massification du nombre d'étudiants les
riches et des rues des raisons ya
tellement de difficultés sociales en
particulier pour les étudiants
aujourd'hui à la fois en matière de
logement en matière de d'égalité
face au vécu des évidences avec le le
petit la très grande difficulté quel
enseignement à distance selon vous ce
bac il est déjà de dévaloriser dont j'ai
passage parce que il faut sans doute
réfléchir à une année un peu prolongé
qui permettent de rattraper cet écart
considérable de 40% cité par les
allemands mais qui peut être le même
chez nous parce que 2 n'oubliez pas que
la politique gouvernementale
on n'est pas forcément toujours d'accord
avec elle mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
jean michel blanquer ra a essayé
notamment en primaire de d'augmenter les
effectifs d'enseignants de manière à ce
qu'ils aient moins d'étudiants et il ya
une vraie politique je dirais
relativement social qui a été mise en
place
il ne faut pas évidemment en tirer la
conclusion que les diplômes ne valent
rien au contraire au contraire mais on
fait attaquer pour moi essentiellement l
école primaire je suis un peu plus
inquiet pour les collèges et les lycées
nicolas un bailli sont à écouter la
déclaration de frédéric vidal il a réagi
à cette polémique cette semaine et qui
dure depuis un certain temps maintenant
notamment à la sorbonne ou rouler note
de nice sur 20 seront maintenues mais
pas celle en dessous pour ce deuxième
semestre
à écouter ce qu'on a dit frédéric vidal
la ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
cette délibération porte une atteinte
directe à la qualité des diplômes
délivrés par l'université et ce faisant
à l'avenir de ces étudiants qui
souhaitent préserver la valeur de leur
formation
voilà nicolas bay ses lunettes qui avait
réclamé 1 que les notes ne soit pas en
deçà de 10 sur 20 et ça a fait beaucoup
réagir quelle est la vôtre votre
réaction
je partage la réaction de la ministre le
fait de maintenir un contrôle continu ou
le tribunal administratif impose que
seuls les notes de 10 sur 20 au dessus
de 10 sur 20 soit retenu sa peau cela
donne alors sa peau cela donne après je
relativise sa peau cela donne sur une
petite période
de cinq années d'études safa sera la
donne sur un trimestre c'est pas ça non
plus qui va bouleverser le la qualité du
diplôme obtenu par les étudiants et il y
a une vraie révolution
oui la ministre est dans son rôle
elle essaye de préserver une qualité
maximum de l'enseignement mais il faut
aussi faire face à l'angoissé étudiants
qui depuis parcours super toutes ces
réformes qui sont intervenus ont le
sentiment d'être un peu pas noté donc
c'est une décision de justice un qui a
donné raison à au syndicat étudiant aura
donc il quoi m'en tenir compte même si
la ministre peut continuer à apposer la
qualité d'enseignement
c'est une mission du sist son peut pas
revenir dessus
alors il ya une autre étude très
intéressante une estimation qui a été
faite par des chercheurs de l'université
de georgetown et de la banque mondiale
écoutez les résultats de cette étude on
parle du revenu et la perte de revenus
qu'impliquent ces mois de retard à
l'école c'est très intéressant regardez
par exemple si le pays x ferme ses
écoles et ses universités pendant quatre
mois
cette perte serait de 2 5% par an
pendant la durée de vie professionnelle
d'un élève le monde pourrait perdre
jusqu'à 10 milliards de dollars sur la
génération à venir en raison des
fermetures d'écoles aujourd'hui nicolas
bailly son n'y pense pas mais ça ça
aussi des répercussions sur le pib
j'ai du mal à croire en cette étude
honnêtement magazine moi le vrai risque
économique que joie c'est celui que j'ai
évoqué au début de haut début de ce
débat c'est de se dire que les étudiants
là vont être confrontés les étudiants
qui sortiront avec un diplôme en fin
d'année scolaire se retrouveront
confrontés à un marché du travail en
grande grande tension face à une crise
économique qui va arriver à la rentrée
de septembre et ses étudiants rentreront
plus tard sur le marché du travail
je ne pense pas qu'ils auront toute leur
vie
un déficit salariales liées à cette
période ceux de mai 68 l'ont pas eu
c'est votre avis jean paul huchon je
pense que cette étude comme l'a dit
nicolas bes a tout il ya un instant
cette étude est un peu primaire c'est à
calais d'ailleurs elle est fondée sur
des critères américains comme filles on
pouvait déduire de la valeur du diplôme
a ensuite le salaire sur cinq ou dix
années et des futurs des futurs
travailleurs qui auront vécu c'est
peut-être effectivement particulièrement
les pays un peu moins développés mais
surtout sa touche en amérique que des
gens qui ont un système scolaire qui est
beaucoup plus coûteux et qui n'offrent
pas toutes les garanties du système
français
alors on va parler de des répercussions
de ce confinement ont parlé
d'enseignement à distance selon une
étude de l'eau cdo et ça a été plutôt
bien gérée en france l ocde qui dit que
neuf élèves sur dix qui ont 15 ans
aujourd'hui ont accès à un ordinateur
donc c'est relativement dans la bonne
moyenne de l'eau cdo 1 sauf que les
enseignants jeunes sont mal formés alors
est-ce que c'est plutôt vers ça qu'il
faudrait aller dans le monde d'après de
l'éducation nationale nicolas bays j'ai
lu cette étude avec beaucoup d'attention
les enseignants n'étaient pas formés
pour ce qu'on en avait on n'avait pas eu
besoin de mettre en place c'est gentil
de d'accompagnement des élèves à
distance alors oui dans l'avenir il
faudra mieux former les enseignants à
ces outils il faudra certainement
d'ailleurs travailler sur des outils
particulier parce que les enseignants
ont et ont leur encore magie si tous
ensemble les enseignants ou parfois
bricoler avec ce qu'ils avaient sous la
main comme outil pour pouvoir suivre et
pour pouvoir suivre leurs élèves et
continuer à enseigner après attention il
ne faut pas détaché l'enseignant de ses
élèves et un moment il faut qu'il ait
cette relation physique entre
l'enseignant et ses élèves dans une
classe dans un lieu dans un amphithéâtre
et les cours à distance ça vient en
complément ça pourra venir en complément
ça pourrait venir pour les
spécialisations pour des enseignements
supplémentaires mais pas en remplacement
de ou du soutien scolaire on pourrait
l'imaginer ou le soutien scolaire par
exemple ou alors même d'aider ou alors
après le temps scolaire de deux de créer
plus de liens entre les entre les
étudiants et leurs enseignants mais ça
me donnera pas se substituer aux formes
d'enseignement pour que d'aujourd'hui
j'empoigne ils font donc remettre le
face à face est important c'est ce que
dit nicolas bays mais comment est-ce
qu'on vous explique un combo pour les
restaurants mardi écoles et les lycées
nous n'aurons que un entretien
pédagogique ecouter c'est très important
le rapport enseignants enseigner et moi
perso moi je suis très favorable à ce
que l'on reste très proche des élèves et
que l'enseignement à distance
n'envahissent pas tout et là ça a été
et ces cités on s'est trouvé dans une
situation quand même très du site du
point de vue sanitaire donc c'est ça qui
est si fier le fait de passer un système
à distance d'ailleurs les enseignants
ont comme été assez remarquable dans
cette période parce qu'ils ont
énormément accroché à fait nouvelle
méthode
il reste à parfaire leur formation du xx
siècle la formation des enseignants la
formation non seulement pédagogique mais
la formation même humaines des
enseignants psychologique est un petit
peu déficiente encore en france quels
enseignements sont sans jeu de mot
évidemment une collab ace pouvez vous
tirer de cette période de confinement et
des améliorations à apporter
les autres je pense qu'il est encore
trop tôt pour tirer tous les
enseignements de cette crise mais
l'accompagnement des l'accompagnement
des enseignants la formation des
enseignants devraient être renforcés il
faudra aussi nombreuse peut-être des
classes moins nombreuses
c'est depuis le début du quinquennat du
président macro
c'est ce vers quoi on tend on a commencé
avec forcément les moyens de l'état qui
ne sont pas sans fond on a commencé à
dédoubler les classes
là où c'est le plus important notamment
dans les premières années d'école
primaire là où l'apprentissage de la
lecture et de l'écriture se forment pour
éviter des décrochages plus dur par la
suite et oui c'est on voit que c'est de
me classer petit goût sont la forme
idoine d'enseignement merci beaucoup
j'en parlais choix derniers mois vous
avez 30 seront la condition pour que ça
marche mieux chez qui est vraiment un
accompagnement des élèves dès qu'il y
ait du périscolaire au tour des élèves
parce que s'ils ne sont pas accompagnés
constamment le niveau des élèves n'est
pas toujours extraordinaire moi je donne
des cours en ce moment mais c'est
parfois un peu inquiétant donc il faut
un accompagnement et il faut pas perdre
le fil de la discussion avec les élèves
merci beaucoup ce sera donc le mot de la
fin merci jean paul huchon
merci beaucoup nicolas bay est d'avoir
participé à ce débat c'est la fin du
débat politique week end rester avec
nous l'info à suivre
[Musique]